the former mgm grant is now bally's here
on flamingo near las vegas boulevard
the building still stands today but with
a history
many cannot forget these were gaming
chips that were
melted together mementos and memories
these are pictures of both the building
the fire
charlie lombardo shares snapshots
showing the devastation of the deadly
mgm grand fire 40 years ago
this is a crop table this was the casino
cage just burned
just just burned reminders of the
morning the former slot mechanic
survived
it was a fireball video from that day
shows plumes of smoke rising from the
building the aftermath of an electrical
fire in the deli restaurant
it spread through the casino which did
not have sprinklers
lombardo recalls crawling on his hands
and knees to get out
after hearing an overhead announcement
to evacuate the building
i went maybe six eight feet
i thought this is nuts i turned around
and went back
because it was clear behind me
he eventually found an exit but not
before warning colleagues in a coin
counting room to get out
i went and pounded on the door got their
attention
and i as they were opening the door i
could see smoke
coming out of the air vents in that room
there were a lot of people
up and going up and down the hallways
meanwhile firefighters like stanley
grisman's kiss
ran inside there were there were never
any fires like it of course
you know that was pretty pretty dramatic
chris grismanisk has cleared the 17th
and 23rd floors
he came across bodies in the rooms and
hallways
there were so many dead people right at
the elevators
[Music]
that i had to move creating a path to
help people escape to the roof
and get air lifted out by helicopters
here's the helicopter
his wife becky also seen the bodies
later that evening
there were a bunch of them by the
registration desk
and they were literally burned
to death in a motion like running
the former criminal investigator at the
district attorney's office probed the
fire
looking for building code violations to
determine county liability
it was that's terrible and you know you
don't ever forget that
a burning memory with a keepsake a
gaming chip
similar to lombardos just a few items
that remain from that day
on the strip kristen drummond 8 news now